Okay Michael, so here is a, another little game for us
to play. And, what I want you to notice about this
game before I describe it to you in detail is that
we have relaxed yet another one of the constraints. So, we
started out playing two player, zero sum, deterministic games of perfect
information. There's also a finite in there somewhere. From now on
we're just going to assume everything's finite, because why not? And then,
what we did last time. Just a few seconds ago. Is we
relax the deterministic part, so we have two player,
zero sum, non-deterministic games of perfect information, and now
we are going to relax the requirement for perfect information.
So now we're going to look at two player, zero-sum,
possibly non-deterministic games of hidden information. And this is
really important Michael because, this last little bit of
relaxation, going from perfect information to hidden information is
going to be sort of a quantum leap into the
difficult problems of game theory. So this is where
it actually starts to get interesting so we have been
building a foundation so far and now we are
going to get to the interesting and complicated stuff, okay?
>> Wow, one of the things that I learned
just now is that the opposite of perfect is hidden.
>> Yes.
>> I always thought the opposite of perfect is imperfect but okay but hidden.
I guess if I do not have a perfect face I should hide my face.
>> Thats in fact the atomology
of the phrase.
>> Alright, I understand now.
>> Yeah, cool, It's in wikipedia. Here we go, let me describe
the game to you, are you ready? This is a version of
mini poker where there are a set of cards, but they have
no numbers of faces on them they are just red or black, okay.
>> And red is bad, for our hero, Player
A, and black is good for our hero, Player A.
>> Okay?
>> I see.
>> So--
>> Wait. Why's it have to be red?
>> I don't know, man. You know, red. You know how it is. Okay.
So, here are the rules. They're all written down on the screen, but let me
walk through them with you. So A is delta card. Magically. It will be red
or black. and, the probability of it being red or black is 50% each. Okay?
>> Yes.
>> Right. So we have a uniform prior over, over the
color. Now, remember red is bad for A and black is good
for A. So, it's going to turn out without loss of generality, that if A gets
a black card, A's definitely going to hold onto
the card. Okay? Now A gets this card.
B, player B, does not get to see the card. A can choose to either resign or to
hold. If A resigns given a red card, then he looses 20 cents. Okay?
>> Okay. Wait. So A's dealt red. A may resign if
but only if red.
>> Right.
>> And then A loses 20 cents.
>> Okay. Alright, okay.
>> Okay, so this is a betting game. It's not strange it makes perfect
sense its sort of a metaphor for life. Now A can choose to hold instead,
hold the card. Thus requiring B to do something. So if A holds the card B can
either resign or can demand to see the card. Now if B resigns
then A gets 10 cents. Regardless of the color of the card. Okay?
>> Yep.
>> That make sense?
>> Okay. Now if B chooses to see the card, in fact demands to
see the card. Then if the card is red, then A loses 40 cents. But
if the card is black, then A gets 30 cents. And since we're betting, this
means that whatever A wins, B loses and vice versa. That makes it zero sum.
>> Got it.
>> Okay, is this all make sense?
>> Yeah, I
don't know if I can hold all those different numbers in
my head. But I, but the basic pattern of it is,
that as you say Red is, red is bad, black is
good. If A gets a bad card, A can essentially either fold
>> Mm-hm.
>> Right, resign? Or kind of bluff, like hey I've
got this great card and then A and if
B believes that the card is bad then and
calls A or, or, or, and, and just folds then,
then A gets, A wins that. But if B says no I think
maybe you're bluffing and calls him, then
everybody's rewards are more extreme, I guess.
>> >Exactly. So it's just a version of poker. A weird version of poker.
Simple version of poker. But a version of poker, none the less. There's a
minor little detail here which isn't that
important, but you know, notice it's written
that A will A may resign if its red. Basically, A will never resign
on a black card. Because it just doesn't
make any sense. And so there's really, it just,
there's not point in riding it out. Okay.
Because black is always good, sort of, nothing bad
can ever happen to A, if A gets a black card. So there's really sort of no
point in riding anything out. But that's just
a minor detail. Regardless these are the rules. Okay?
>> Okay.
>> You got it? Sure.
>> I'm going to re-draw this as a game tree which might make
it a little easier to keep all the rules in your head.